نيكول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كنت أطلعه دائمًا على مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي ، وكنت دائمًا
أعرض له السجال ومقاطع التدريب الخاصة بي
وطلبت منه النصيحة
ذات يوم معين أنه كان يتحدث
بشكل جيد
أه بسبب حالته ، لم
يتحدث دائمًا  الأفضل ولكن في يوم من الأيام كان
يتحدث بشكل
حاد وواضح جدًا وكان يقول فقط
أن الحركة والرقص يصنعان
مقاتلًا وكنت أتلقى نصيحة
تعرفها عنك تعرف ما الذي يجعل
المقاتل وما يجب أن أفعله
لأكون مقاتلًا جيدًا  وقد قال للتو أنك تعرف
تناول الطعام بشكل صحيح ، آه ، قم بالكثير من الأعمال على الطرق ،
وهذا كل شيء أتذكره حتى
يومنا هذا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] حصلت عليها كهدية بعد وفاة جدي
كتذكار تعرفه
لم يكن من المفترض أن أرتديهم
معركتي الأولى ولكن القدر والقدر كان علي
أن أرتديهم كان من
المفترض أن أرتدي
سروالًا قصيرًا مخصصًا دائمًا كان عليه نيكو على
الحزام وهم  لم تكن جاهزة
[موسيقى]
أعطاني إياها  أعرف الكثير جدًا
من الأشياء الإضافية ، لقد كان الأمر كما لو أنني أعني أنها كانت مجرد ليلة مجنونة مجنونة وكان ذلك أحد الأشياء العديدة التي
جعلت جدي ينبض بالحياة
في ليلة السبت 2 أشعر حقًا
أنه كان على قيد الحياة في تلك الليلة في ذلك الوقت
العديد من الطرق التي تعرفها من خلال الهتافات
في الحشد
كانوا يرددون علي وهو ما لم
أره من قبل من قبل ، لقد رأيت ذلك فقط على
المقاطع بالأبيض والأسود على YouTube
آه ولكن نعم لا ، كان على قيد الحياة أم
ليلة السبت وكان من خلالي  لقد
كان ذلك من خلال السراويل
القصيرة وكان مجرد نعمة ، كما تعلمون
طوال الليل ، لم يكن بإمكاني أن
أحلم بليلة أفضل ،
هدفي الأكبر هو خوض معركة واحدة
في كل مرة
وأنت تعرف أنني أعظم
نيكو  يمكن أن
أكون ولدي مثل هذا
التوقع الكبير بالنسبة لي ومن الواضح
أن الجمهور بأكمله لديه توقعات عالية
بالنسبة لي ، كما
أنه
هدف عظيم أن أكون في أفضل حالاتي
وهذا كل ما يمكنني أن أطلبه
[موسيقى]